[Music]
here to teach me some self-defense
techniques using ordinary household
items this might save your life is our
good friend professional stuntman Steven
ho Steven we're gonna learn and the
break beforehand I saw you stretching
and limbering up and I have not done
that yet so you talk and I'll get limber
okay well in the past we've already
taught you some basic self-defense moves
yes remember your palm thrust you pocket
you [ __ ] you palm tree headbutt head
blows
wow that's for the groin we've done we
were in the groin a lot yes so we're
gonna now we're gonna work on ordinary
items for self-defense and how we can
how that can save your life one day okay
so these are things that might just be
lying around that you can use as weapons
could be in your purse could be in your
bathroom could be in your clarity I
don't carry a purse but all right here
we go so before we do that let's start
with just the basic reminder of a
nightstand so it's a nice thing what do
you mean well in any self-defense
situation or fighting situation you have
to be don't be caught heavy footed you
want to be light on your toes like a cat
right you're talking to the right guy
now
trying to like that not so dancer II
like what do you maybe what is that what
do you mean like way tell me what you
think just a little bit better for
posture this way so you can there you go
we're gonna talk about distance
okay so I'll draw a circle around you
yes and basically this circle is your
critical distance circle it could be
your your danger zone basically it's
your DMZ line okay so so anything this
is what and people should use this
anything that happens outside this zone
is not my concern
everyone circle is different you're a
big guy with the long reach so you have
a very big circle some people have
smaller circles okay so it really
depends and then anyone when anyone
enters this circle they've entered my
zone and I must attack exactly anything
out here is free when I come inside then
it's on now we're engaged okay why is it
not affecting you in any way okay you
like me to iron so that's crazy okay
[Applause]
just letting the blood pool into my shoe
I'm ready now so this is a very
important strategy yes keep it in the
back of your head we're gonna come back
to this but for now we're gonna go back
and just start talking through different
items okay so for example hairspray
everyone has the can of hairspray
somewhere I've got many cans yeah you
don't think much of it but if you do it
properly then obviously you could spray
it in someone's face okay and then you
can just wrap it up in the soma okay you
know that part it rehearse okay a comb
ordinary item very simple everyone has a
comb yeah
what they don't realize is that the
teeth of the comb are actually really
really sharp yeah and if you use it
effectively yeah just this is gonna hurt
yeah that's right yeah and you can go to
the neck right thank you can take it
underneath to the groin you see a
pattern here Steven it's self-defense
yeah I know but everything goes to the
groin eventually anyway you could use
this as effectively as a razor yeah if
you do it properly
also a rush
29 out Sharpie pen sure to my favorites
oh so single stock rail mean about
somebody hurt their feelings
drop your pen it's legal it's small you
can carry in your pocket you can get in
your you know thing there hang on to it
but if you use it with the proper
technique you got you could actually go
right through something we broke that
sharpie
that's okay okay so you can actually
puncture through you know a lot of skin
yeah okay you know that would really
work going to the gland right there and
it's really about your technique so you
have to go fast enough
yeah have enough all right so you'll be
like Oh mr. Brian I really love your
show look your autograph and then once
you're comfortable you can go and just
[Applause]
dissapoint what just happened I really
believe Sharpie does make the best pen
what you got there pal this is no gray
one just a cup of coffee okay could be
any sort of liquid but if you use it
properly especially something hot yeah
you wait until someone encroaches your
critical distance right let's before
yeah then you could spit it in their
face and then you can follow up with
take to the garage to the client so I've
been doing stuff on you would you like
to try something yeah okay on Ben okay
okay that's not you it's only fair I've
been hurting you would you like to hurt
Ben okay he'd come at me
[Music]
[Applause]